estamos en comunicación con la senadora
rosa gálvez senador independiente en el
senado canadiense como la barrosa gálvez
muy bien estoy muy contenta es verano
gracias por la invitación paloma muy
contenta de conversar contigo esta
mañana rosa gálvez como la con la
contacte en esta ocasión porque
recientemente la semana pasada el
viernes pasado justamente se aprobó por
la cámara de los comunes
habiendo pasado ya por el senado
canadiense la ley institu ando
instituyendo perdón el mes del
patrimonio latinoamericano qué significa
para usted esta está esta aprobación de
esta de este proyecto de ley
eso excelentes noticias para la
comunidad latinoamericana que vive en
las diferentes ciudades del canadá
este proyecto hace estaba en marcha
desde hace muchos años debo reconocer la
iniciativa del senador todavía se en
berga del caucus conservador que nos que
inició este es este proyecto de ley y
que lo ha soportado hasta verdaderamente
hasta el último desde porque falleció el
senador el año pasado en colombia
durante una última visita recientemente
y éste nos dejó este proyecto de ley y
yo estoy muy muy contenta de que el
proyecto haya pasado con unanimidad en
las dos cámaras y definitivamente vamos
a ver la manera como vamos a ignorar al
senador en berga qué significa para los
latinoamericanos de canadá tener un mes
en el que se va a celebrar el patrimonio
de los de los latinoamericanos de origen
canadiense acá
mi idea ha habido muchas olas de
inmigración latinoamericana al canadá
entonces tenemos muchos latinoamericanos
que proviene en diferentes países de
centro y sur américa y que han
contribuido al desarrollo social
económico político de canadá y no había
una una manera un momento especial
oficial por el cual se reconociera esta
contribución entonces este proyecto de
ley
para festejar que que nos va a permitir
de festejar justamente la herencia
latinoamericana y en el desarrollo de
canadá es extremadamente importante para
los 300.000 latinoamericanos que
habitamos
canadá cree usted que en canadá se
conoce más allá de que este mes lo va a
ser celebrar esta presencia
latinoamericana en canadá pero cree
usted que existe un un conocimiento no
diría yo reconocimiento pero por lo
menos conocimiento de lo que los
latinoamericanos han aportado a canadá
aquí es una pregunta muy interesante que
yo tuve que responderla cuando me
aparecí como como testigo en el estudio
de esta ley y es lo siguiente no es de
que la nos confunde mucho no a veces nos
pueden confundir con italianos con
portugueses con griegos yo te lo puedo
decir personalmente porque mis hijos
por muchos años la gente de aquí pensaba
de que ellos eran de origen italiano de
origen griego y el origen
latinoamericano no estaba después bueno
evidentemente cuando el nafta aparece
cuando la leen aparece el intercambio el
libro intercambio entre el méxico y eeuu
y canadá y eeuu entonces
la primera idea que te pasa del
latinoamericano es el mexicano pero en
realidad hay muchos más que mexicanos
aquí en américa en canadá y en las
américas entonces es importante también
el geográficamente estamos unidos
estamos unidos por acuerdos bilaterales
individuales con con países
latinoamericanos e individualmente pero
también conjuntamente porque hacemos
parte de ciertos mercados de ciertos
acuerdos en grupo y entonces había que
reconocer esto no y por ejemplo como lo
he dicho quien ha ido a ver un
espectáculo del circo de soleil se da
rápidamente cuenta que hay una hay una
inspiración hay una influencia de las
culturas prehispánicas culturas
autóctonas de la américa latina entonces
ha venido a influenciar la comida los
productos agrícolas la quinoa no hoy día
que la conocemos que está en todos los
platos en todos los restaurantes viene
de américa de américa latina entonces
este también algunos
algunas palabras algunos lenguajes y hay
algunas maneras de decir mundo cuando
hablan de la hora latinoamericana cuando
hablan del optimismo americano ya
entonces nos identificamos y ellos nos
identifican con una manera de ser el
modo de ser latinoamericano es muy
epikurean o el placer de disfrutar el
momento presente la amistad de lo que lo
que tenemos nuestro vaso siempre está a
mitad lleno no está entidad vestido rosa
gálvez usted es senador independiente en
el senado canadiense muchas gracias de
nada paloma y para que nos volvemos a
hablar exactamente eso es pero yo
también